impossible de ne pas penser à l'
aventure des frères montgolfier dès les
premiers instants un décollage des
montgolfières est toujours une opération
impressionnante
après le ballon d'air chaud vous porte
dans les airs une activité touristique
particulièrement adapté aux paysages de
sologne et de touraine alors on vient de
décoller on est pile poil sur le domaine
donc de cheverny juste devant nous il ya
toute la forêt de cheverny avec le plan
d'eau le golf de cheverny re
way manu store soit 5 on prend la
direction de fougères sur bièvre
c'est assez impressionnant d'être dans
un tout petit
environnement aussi haut et aussi loin
du sol
mais des paysages sont vraiment vraiment
jolie le bruit est assez impressionnant
et la toile aussi tout et nombre en vélo
on peut pas on peut pas tout voir en
voiture on peut pas tout voir et là
c'est vrai qu'en montgolfière tout
s'offrent à nous on est tout simplement
dans un balcon volant un balcon volant
sur les châteaux de la loire très prisé
des touristes et des locaux l'entreprise
au gré du vent avec ses 7 montgolfière
connaît un début de saison estivale
époustouflant avec des gens sont restés
un petit peu renfermé chez eux avec le
avec le co videla c'est vrai que
maintenant on est con est libre
mais la montgolfière cesser tout ce qui
a pu libre quoi
pour une heure de vol pour deux
personnes il en coûte 380 euros mais les
clients sont choyés
autres
et chaque passager repart avec des
souvenirs hors du commun c'est beau on
voit des zones d'ombré des zones de
lumière il ya beaucoup de bois oui c'est
verdoyant c'est c'est vraiment c'est
magnifique ce sera aussi le nombre de
manoir de beaux domaines de piscine tout
ça c'est des choses qu'on voit pardon
oui
[Musique]